A 19 second video
of Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky
has gotten millions of views on Twitter.
The viral video
shows Zelensky
speaking at a press conference
on the anniversary of Russia's invasion.
And it sure sounds from this short clip
like he made a dramatic declaration
that Americans have to fight in Ukraine.
The US will have to send their sons
and daughters
exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war.
And they will have to fight
because it's
nature that we're talking about
and they will be dying and God forbid,
because it's a horrible thing.
Critics of American financial
and military support
for Ukraine
have reacted furiously to this clip
and shared it on social media.
They include Republican Senator
Mike Lee of Utah
and Monica Crowley,
a former Trump administration
Treasury Department spokesperson.
Crowley wrote.
Zelensky now directly threatening us
and claiming American sons and daughters
will have to fight and die for Ukraine.
However, Zelensky did not actually make
that claim.
This 19 second video
takes him way out of context.
The full clip shows
that he wasn't talking about Americans
fighting in Ukraine at all.
Here is what really happened.
Zelensky was asked
about what he'd say to Americans
who think the US is providing
too much support for Ukraine.
He first thanked the American people,
President Biden and Congress
for their support.
He urged Americans to see Ukrainians
as similar to themselves.
He urged the U.S.
not to give up
its leadership position in the world.
And then he said this
The US is never
going to give
up on the need to member states
if it happens
so that Ukraine, due to various opinions
and we can and depleting of assistance
loses.
Russia is going to enter
Baltic states, native member states
and then
the US will have to send their sons
and daughters
exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war.
And they will have to fight because it's
nature that we're talking about
and they will be dying.
God forbid,
because it's a horrible thing to
I wish them
peace and Ukrainian
support to the United States.
People are free to criticize
that actual comment from Zelensky,
but he was clearly not saying
the US
military should fight on Ukrainian soil.
He was saying the US would have to fight
in other countries.
NATO's countries
the US has formally committed
to help defend
if Russia invaded those countries later.
So as always,
when you come across a sensational
but short clip on social media,
it's always a good idea
to look for the extended footage to